hey everyone how you doing
i'm i'm not to be honest for some reason
i'm so freaking nervous right now
my whole body is shaking i can feel my
chest right there
normally it starts to go away by now but
today it's just getting worse so
if you want to see
someone suffering in pain you came to
the right talk
hopefully it's going to fade away
maybe this is the reason why i'm quite
nervous today
i might say some things that upset the
church of the manger and design
i'm going to be talking about
um
you know yeah i think it's good to
to challenge things right nothing's ever
perfect so in this talk
i'm just going to look at some of the
aspects of the major design that
maybe maybe
could be improved if that's possible to
improve anything in domain driven design
some people on twitter might say that's
impossible
um
that's the nerfs if you if you haven't
read the domain design book before
haven't heard anything about domain
driven design that's okay it's a bit of
a beginner talk
if you have if you have read it if
you've used it if you've been applying
it for years you know maybe you might
find it useful as well so
let's let's just get straight into it
so here's one of the
one of the kinds of criticisms that
we'll see from time to time about domain
driven design so what's this guy talking
about dimensional design is just awful
everyone i've ever spoken to that claims
to understand it has a different
definition that can't be applied by
others utterly useless
might as well use tarot cards to derive
boundaries from so you know if there's
one thing you take away from this
conference
tarot card driven architecture maybe
you know similar similar comments here
someone someone read one of the books
likes the ideas but
getting a bit caught up in all of this
to major in design terminology like you
know
bounded context ubiquitous language
are we developing software or are we
philosophists what what does this
terminology mean
some people take a different approach in
the way they provide feedback we can see
um
dan brew and james morkum here
have been proposing alternative
alternative definitions to some demand
during design terms
you know they're not they're not being
critical they're just having a bit of a
laugh and a joke but
you know fifty percent of jokes are true
are true
uh all of mine are true so if you're
ever doubting all my jokes are true
but you know this
this bounded context worked you know it
doesn't doesn't always land with people
um
it's got something to do with language
so james is talking about linguo spheres
and then there's a guy called herman he
wrote about this stuff and he
you know he had a bit of a bit of a poke
at the words the phrase ubiquitous
language um
he's got a very
very limited space of applicability
as kind of the opposite of ubiquitous
um
so yeah but it'll be good to talk to the
church of ddd and get their thoughts on
this one you know
what
what they mean by ubiquitous exactly
maybe it's a special kind of ubiquitous
and then we've got jeremy miller who's
often at these ndc conferences
he he just you know he's a bit more
direct with his feedback in his opinions
of domain driven design
and he's just talking about every
codebase he's ever seen that uses it
now add your own
add your own word there
so
i think people in in the domain design
community actually know that there's
opportunity for improvement um a long
time ago
uh eric he was talking about you know if
he could write the book again he might
do some things differently
acknowledging
that
these problems people have with ddd you
know
if he could do it again he might explain
or write the book in a different way so
that people didn't have these problems
maybe he you know
so what he he said this this one he said
i you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna he's gonna reorder the book to
put a different order of preference
around certain concepts
so you know he put a lot of the
strategic stuff at the back around
architecture and things
he wants to put that in chapter two or
three
so i found this really inspiring you
know i was i was
thinking about what he was saying here
and i was like you know he's he's got
his own alternative dvd timeline
what if i had mine
what if i could have my own alternative
vdd timeline
and i looked at all of these things
people were saying and criticizing and i
could change history
so that they were all saying
wonderful things every single time
so i thought well he wants to reorder
some chapters
maybe we can be a bit more adventurous
than that you know if we're gonna if
we're gonna have an alternative timeline
and we can do whatever we want in
history
what would an ambitious alternative
timeline look like
and so i thought
what if we just take one chapter
and throw the rest away
would that be an alternative ddd
timeline worth exploring
so that's what i'm going to do
in my alternative timeline today i'm
going to talk you through chapter 8 in
the book which is called breakthrough
and i think this is the hidden treasure
because i i really feel like
this this one chapter i've read it a lot
of times actually and whenever i read
the book i always feel like
hello why doesn't why don't people get
this part of ddd this is what we think
of but then they're all getting trapped
around certain words and
little patterns in codes
so chapter eight i think is the hidden
treasure it's been there all along in
the book
so i thought well let's put that as the
first chapter in the book
i'm like well actually it's my
alternative timeline let's just put that
at the front and not have any other bits
in the book
so
maxine uh
he you know he likes his chapter two he
calls it the forgotten chapter so maybe
after this talk um go back and check it
out and hopefully
if you've got any concerns around ddd
this might help you connect back with
the core concepts and points and what
it's all really about
nerves haven't gone away at all
so i'm going to talk you through the
chapter eight in the book
with some of my commentary on top and my
observations
so i've split it down into three parts i
think there are three nice takeaways
from this chapter and the first one is
what i'm calling intuitions
of a seasoned domain modeler so
the first part of this chapter
really exciting i think really sets the
scene in a nice way it doesn't tell us
much about dddd but you know he's
talking about
after a long new york winter of
refactoring now i i love refactoring i
love winter and i love new york so i'm
like is he writing his chapter for me or
something because no i just i just read
that and i just i can imagine it you
know
coming into new york every day it's dark
nights you're refactoring in this dark
outside in the office with your
colleagues it really sets the scene for
me but
that's not really part of the main room
design that the full the full opening of
the chapter is talking about
after a long new york winter of
refactoring we had arrived at a model
that captured some of the key knowledge
of the domain
and a design that did some real work for
the application
we were developing a core part of a
large application for managing
syndicated loans in an investment bank
so
all of those details don't really matter
too much it's just setting the scene for
all of the bits that are coming next so
you know it's important to understand
some of these details
and so then still at the start of the
chapter
he starts
this boy can write a story he knows how
to build you know get a point across and
grab your attention he's like
when intel wants to build a billion
dollar factory a bit a bit of name
dropping throwing some big numbers in
there
um they need a loan that's too big for
any single lending company to take on so
the lenders form a syndicate that pulls
its resources to support a facility so
don't don't need to worry about all of
those details not critical to the story
but
now we get we get the sense here that
he's working on this big interesting
project
intel billion dollar factories
something's important something
important happening here
we're not doing dvd on a to-do list app
in the latest javascript framework
it's a bit different
so then we get to
this
um
talking about his team's specific role
in this project so an investment bank
usually acts as a syndicate leader
coordinating transactions and other
services
our project was to build software to
track and support this whole process so
you know we can see what they're getting
up to what what his role is what his
team's building
software to track that process of
managing syndicated loans big big loans
so we now understand what's been
happening in that new york winter a bit
more deeply you know they weren't
hanging out at times square
just chilling out with the with their
dudes you know they're actually really
doing some refactoring so
we were feeling pretty good
four months before
we had been in trouble with a completely
unworkable inherited code base
who's worked who's inherited a code base
that wasn't completely unworkable
let's check let's chat later i need to
verify that first
so
whether it's true or not you know we
always talk about other people's code
but you know they've inherited this code
they spent all all winter refactoring
here and they've got this model that
they're happy with this model so it's
kind of diminishing the design right we
try and model it
try and create a nice model in the code
but we don't know yet really
is this model actually useful or is it
just some developers who like
perfectionists creating beautiful models
in the code
is there any real value to this or are
they just perfectionists let's take on
the next step
but there were some disconcerting
science
we kept stumbling over unexpected
requirements
i've highlighted that word because you
know i think
no requirements are unexpected really um
but i'll let him have that that that
complicated the design
a major example was the creeping
understanding
that the shares in a facility were only
a guideline
so i spent all winter refactoring got
this nice model but
there's some some doubts
there at this point we don't know are
they just perfectionists it needs to be
even more perfect
or is this you know
relevant to the work they're doing is
there some consequence of this that's
going to affect the projects they're
working on
so
i think an important lesson here which
stands out to me which is relevant on
most of the projects i would say is you
build that first part you build that
happy path the 80 20 rule
and then you start getting all of these
requirements that come up
and it's it's easy
um
it's easy to just think
uh
all these requirements are necessary
but here
what what they're noticing is that it
feels like the code they're writing
is too complex with the requirements
they've got they don't know why
it's just that it's kind of like a
feeling at this point
there's not much precision in what
they're describing it's just
this doesn't feel right
i'll come back to that shortly so
here they talk about we had accommodated
this by adding loan adjustments to the
model
the concept of loan adjustments isn't
key here don't worry too much about the
domain but the point is
refinements of this kind allowed us to
keep up as the rules of various
transactions became clearer
but
complexity was increasing and we did not
seem to be converging quickly onto solid
functionality so
what they've done here
they're sensing that their model
isn't isn't perfect
um and they've com they've added this
new concept into their model
and it's made it easier to add some of
these
unexpected requirements but they're
still feeling like it's a bit of a hack
it's not the code's still getting out of
control and becoming too complex and i
think this is where
this is where
people who are good at domain modeling
start to have these feelings about
this isn't right it could be designed
better whereas
if you
if you're just looking at requirements
and implementing them in code you might
be happy at this point we've got the
requirements we've written the code
i don't see that this thing's getting
out of control and complex i'm just
moving on to next year a ticket
so i think what they what are they
getting across at this point is
is really something that only happens
with like expert domain modelers or
seasoned domain modelers it's like
something's not right here we can
implement these requirements in code but
it's just not right and they're starting
to question their understanding of the
domain itself
do we not understand the domain we're
working in and that's causing our code
to be more complex than it needs to be
and i think whenever i read that chapter
that always stands out to me and i'm
always wondering
how many developers in in their lifetime
and this question is for you
how many times have you been
writing some code building a system and
thought to yourself
this code is too complex
not because you haven't used some design
pattern or not because you've taken a
shortcut but because
your understanding of the domain
isn't good enough and that's causing the
code to be complex how often have you
had that conversation in your team
for me
it doesn't happen very often
don't really look at code and say
if i understood this domain better that
code could be much simpler so
just an interesting observation
so back to the story eric and his team
they're they're getting this the feeling
has grown a bit more now and they're
like okay we've got we've got a basic
design problem here but we don't know
what it is
so that's that's the first part i think
that part of the chapter is is giving
you some insights in what it's like to
to work with an experienced domain model
or be an experienced domain modeler when
you can see the code is more complex
than it needs to be for the domain
you're working in that that's the first
thing that intuition
in the second part of the chapter i
think gets more more about um
the value of
using the domain to drive your software
and practices around that we start to
see more of the benefits of this
approach rather than just feelings
so
suddenly one week it dawned on us what
was wrong so they've identified the
problem our model tied together the
facility and loan shares in a way that
was not appropriate for their business
so their model in code
the way they
designed those objects and the
relationships between them
that there wasn't enough alignment
between the way the code was structured
and the way people in the business
thought about those concepts and the
relationships between them so they've
identified
part of the code and the part of the
domain that they don't understand well
enough
yep and so then they get to the white
board with some domain experts
they're like
that's the thinking process here right
they're like this code is too complex
they didn't think
let's let's you know let's have a tdd
session on it and keep refactoring until
it gets nice so they were like let's
step away from the code let's get some
domain experts and let's go to the
whiteboard and understand the problem
better before we come back to this basic
design problem we found
so they walked through numerous
scenarios using this new model they
created and i've highlighted the word
scenarios here because i think that's
really important when trying to
understand the domain and create models
so it's very easy to fool yourself when
you stay high level
um thinking you understand something
especially at a domain it's easy to
think oh we understand the happy path
actually
once you get into it and you start
implementing code sometimes you're like
oh
what should happen here
either you stop working try and get some
clarification
or you make an assumption
i'll just throw an exception that'll be
fine never happens
whereas
when you go through concrete scenarios
you
you can't make assumptions about how
things work it's it's there it's very
specific
so eric created this model exploration
whirlpool which is you know a good
approach for anyone i think especially
beginners to think about how to create a
domain model how to make sure that
you're balancing knowledge of the domain
with the code itself and
he was talking about those feelings this
is a way to address those feelings to go
through some concrete scenarios
and
here's a technique which
wasn't around when the book was written
but it's a technique i found very useful
which is called example mapping
basically
there's a few different ways you can do
this let me give you an example of one
time i did it so i worked with um
an austrian company
the codebase is in german very difficult
but basically that wasn't the problem
the problem was
the team would be given some
requirements
and a deadline
and
the team kept getting unexpected
requirements or they kept finding
unexpected use cases and the team never
hit their deadline
on another situation
we had these vague requirements and we
spent two weeks
trying to implement like one feature it
was like we tried it like that doesn't
seem to make sense it doesn't work we go
back to the domain experts and they
would say oh yeah when that happens
when the truck's late then you have to
trigger this workflow
and basically we spent two weeks hitting
our head against the wall trying to
understand this domain whereas if we
would have done one hour of example
mapping we would have understood that in
we could have gone through very specific
concrete details so example mapping you
can do it in different ways but
in this example here
we have an action a user wants to
perform and then we have different
scenarios and the events that happen in
each of those scenarios so in this
example we've got a shopper request a
refund
if it's two to three weeks after the
purchase the vouchers are offered that's
the domain events if it's less than two
weeks you get the shopper gets refunded
so it's actually a very simple technique
but when you take some requirements
some obvious requirements like just
implementing a new feature and you do
example mapping and you let your
developers and testers go crazy on it
they'll find all kinds of edge cases and
use cases you weren't thinking about
before it's getting really into the
domain understanding it much better and
with the austrian company i was talking
about
we solve that problem of everything
being delivered late on time by doing we
did example mapping for one hour in the
sprint before so if in sprint one we'll
do some example mapping on the what
we're gonna do in sprint two we found
all of these extra edge cases under
something to make much better
and we went back to the business and
said
we found all these edge cases what
should happen should we build this one
should we ignore this one and sometimes
it was like yeah we'll take that not
that don't worry about that and
sometimes it was like wow
this this this part of the domain is
much more complex when we realized we're
gonna take the whole feature back think
about that some more so
that that's why i think the model
exploration whirlpool
focusing on scenarios that is really
that's basically 90 of my job um
but let's just talk through some
concrete scenarios such as you know
if i was going to write a click bait
title
one simple trick to create better domain
models
talk through concrete scenarios that's
boring
so in the book
here's eric doing this he's going
through a concrete scenario with his
domain experts
diagram says that borrower has chosen to
draw an initial 50 million from the 100
million committed and they're three
lenders so
talking about very concrete details here
in reality
once we've done this once you plug in
those concrete values to make it
specific we can say what if there were
five lenders what if it was 20 million
you know we can start to see all these
different variations but if we stay too
high level
we miss all that complexity that's why
it's important for scenarios
anyway back to the story
we had two deep insights after these
whiteboard sessions we had two deep
insights
first was the realization that our
investments and loan investments were
just two special cases of a general and
fundamental concept
shares
shares of a facility
shares of a loan shares of a payment
distribution
don't worry too much about all those
details don't worry about learning that
domain or anything but the key point is
you know they've spent some time with
the domain experts going through
concrete scenarios being very specific
with numbers and filling in all the
details and they found this hidden
concept in their domain of shares
now is their big moment of breakthrough
suddenly on the basis of this new way of
looking at the domain we could run
through every scenario we had ever
encountered relatively effortlessly
uh much more simply than ever before so
that's the real value of good modeling
all those awkward edge cases that were
difficult to implement making the code
complex
by spending some time with domain
experts understanding the problem better
they were actually able to create a
model which made things much easier
but there's okay there's a twist coming
up in a minute so when i quickly
emphasize the concept of breakthroughs
so what we just saw they had a
breakthrough in their domain knowledge
and that led to a breakthrough in the
software this concept of shares
understanding the business better
allow them to create a very different
model and all of the concepts and
relationships and other new features
it was all working much better much more
easier to adapt that's why breakthroughs
are important
even if you
work with your domain experts around the
whiteboard
and you learn something about the domain
but it's like it's not not changing your
view much if you keep doing that at some
point you'll get to a big breakthrough
that'll have a big impact on your code
right so you've got to keep going at
that keep working at it if it feels like
you have a one-hour workshop with some
domain experts
and you're like
i learned a bit but not too much
you've got to keep going just keep at it
keep learning more
and you might get to a big breakthrough
like shares
and when you do that when you can create
the better model improve your
understanding
because your model matches the way the
business talk about these concepts
it's going to be much easier to
translate
the conversation with the main experts
into the code so it has a number of
benefits it just keeps on getting better
so here's the twist in the tail
so eric and his team they found this
nice new model it worked all really well
and they felt sick
because like every project they had an
urgent deadline coming up and they
didn't actually have the time to
refactor their code
so what's going to happen in the final
part of this story
if my nerves will just
not get any worse for the next 10
minutes you will find out
so in this part
i think it's characterized by investment
in part two we saw the value of
being domain driven working with domain
experts getting more knowledge we saw
the benefits of this improved model in
this part
moving more into design and code how how
it can pay off in the long term
so as the final part of the chapter he
talks about the gospel of refactoring is
that you always go in small steps
and everything keeps working if anything
if you make it if you take a small step
and it doesn't work just do a git revert
go back take another small step
but this is the real world
where things don't always go to plan
where things that you
see at conferences and reading blog
posts
that perfect world
meets reality so what happened is
to refactor our code to this new model
would require a lot of support in code
but there wouldn't there would be few if
any stable stopping points in between so
he's got this old model
they spent four months over winter
creating this beautiful model
which they were happy with and now
they're like that old thing
we need to get rid of it completely and
have this nice new model
but we'll let we'll let them off but you
know it's just the point that in reality
we talk about small steps smaller
factorings
but in this situation that wasn't
possible um
so here's here's one of the most i'd
probably say
possibly the most interesting parts of
this whole chapter
so eric he goes to his project manager
and he's saying look
we need to refer to this code but we've
got this urgent deadline coming up and i
don't know what eric said that project
manager but the project manager is like
don't worry dudes
i'll handle the heat you do the
refactoring
and i'll block any
any problems coming your way
um and he said you know he's always had
tremendous admiration for the courage
and trust it took the project manager to
make that decision
and that for me is another interesting
stopping point another interrogation
point
in this chapter so firstly
what would you have done in his
situation
if you think
oh we can create a much nicer model
but it's risking this deadline which is
already late
but you believe that this model will
make things much easier in the long run
would you would people in your team
would you have the courage
to do that to say that your project
manager or product manager or
whoever needs that decision or maybe you
don't have to
maybe you don't need to make that
question maybe your team is empowered to
make those decisions by yourself
um
and look i guess looking more
retrospectively have you done that have
you ever
delayed
a business deliverable to refactor your
code and make it better in a modeling
sense in the main modeling sense
um and i think the third part here
is the most interesting
not have you done that
would you have been able to do that
do you have a good relationship with
your the main experts project managers
product managers that
if you needed some time to improve the
quality of your system to create a
better model could you even have that
conversation do you have a good
relationship with those people like eric
and his project manager had a great
reputation there
like i think back in my career where i
probably wouldn't even have been able to
ask that question because i just
didn't have a good relationship so
now there's a point here that if you
want to create great software
the relationships do matter and this
gives us a good example of that so then
what happens next in the chapter is they
they refactor the code
the project manager lets them do it
everything goes nice and happy
otherwise he probably wouldn't have
written about it
but they they they discovered this new
concept now they they uncovered this the
main concept of shares and now eric and
his team
they uncovered this new concept called
the sharepie
uh and this sharepie he says here became
the unifying theme of the whole
application
and they used it to discuss the system
domain experts business experts and
engineers developers
this sharepie concept was part of their
modeling code and it became the way they
spoke about the whole system even when
they weren't talking about the code and
it says here um
even the marketing people used it to
explain the features to prospective
customers so
you know this
this journey they went on from
i feel like i feel like this code's a
bit too complex
let's try and understand the domain
better
now they've got this new concept that's
spread out all the way to marketing
that was the pause where i was supposed
to make a joke about marketing but
i thought i wouldn't today um but i i do
want to emphasize which is this which i
think is not appreciated enough
sometimes
um that
you know we talk about domain driven yes
the domain should drive our code but i
also think it works the other way and i
think people don't realize this enough
rather than just looking in the domain
for concepts in your code
sometimes you need to actually add new
concepts to the domain that's what they
did here they added this concept of a
sharepie it's not a one-way relationship
and if you see that as a developer
if you think you know it's not i'm not
taking requirements and implementing
them into a good model but you know i
can actually go into the domain add some
new concepts and change things you know
they added sharepie
that became a part of their system the
marketing team used it they changed the
domain
when they were implementing it they
found a better model in software
and that model in software was actually
a better conceptual model for the domain
itself so you know i think it's really
important to have that two-way approach
what else is in here
yeah yeah cover that
and i think
since the domain driven design book has
been written the way we build software
the modern product management has also
arrived at the same solution a lot of
people a lot of um
product consultants like marty kagan
melissa perry
um if you're if you're a developer i
would recommend going to some product
conferences like minor products and
they're all talking about like this
whole team innovation about the product
manager is just a facilitator and it's
the engineers the testers who actually
come up with a lot of product ideas and
solutions
i think that's what eric was
getting at in that chapter with the
sharepie like they were
not just
implementing the requirements but they
were shaping the product itself
so i think that's another interesting
thing i think
these concepts have become more
mainstream and they're talking about
these concepts of product management
conferences but it's not it's not
something i see in every company so
my question to you is
when was the
when was the last time like someone in
your team
came up with a product feature
when was the last time your team you're
you're um i'm talking like engineers or
testers
when was the last time you came up with
this like share pie whatever sharepoint
is in your company when was the last
time that happened and if it's not
happening maybe that's something to
think about maybe that's something you
could be doing more of getting your team
more involved in the product itself more
into the domain more
more identifying opportunities solutions
and new features
so getting to the end now
just going to finish off this chapter
so just weeks after the release of the
sharepoi version of the software
they noticed another awkward aspect of
their model
that was complicating their design
so if you think about the evolution they
inherited the code base
they refactored it over winter in new
york with a nice model they then threw
that model away and built the new
sharepoint model and now they're seeing
again
oh
actually this design we thought was
perfect isn't perfect there's a whole
area over here that can be improved
again with that um improvements in
domain knowledge and i think i think
that's important
like
if you if you keep making those steps if
you keep learning more about the domain
and updating your model
you might realize oh
you know we're almost at the top of
mount everest this model can't be any
better but really you might be like
not even halfway up there might be like
so much more about the domain you can
learn to improve your code so you know
keep every time you make a breakthrough
it helps you to see
the net other bits of your knowledge in
your model
that weren't as good as you thought they
were before that
and then the final part of the chapter
this
is concept to investment basically
after improving their model
it was actually easier for them to add
new features they were adding new
features faster than they were at the
start of the project
so i think you know it's a bit of a
choose your adventure scenario here at
the start of a project it's always easy
to add new features the code base is
clean there's no legacy you got a nice
f1 car really quick to get stuff done
adding a text box to a web page
20 minutes deployed to production
amazing but over time
code gets more complex harder to work
with things take longer
everyone gets a bit stressed out
deadlines being missed that formula one
car has turned into an old banger no one
likes it anymore everyone wants to work
on a nice new code base
but actually
that is not inevitable there's a choice
here
because the more you work on a system
the more you learn about the domain
and really if you think about that that
should make you go faster right the more
you understand the business you'll be
able to add new features faster
so if you continue to gain domain
knowledge
and reflect that in your systems
you might go from an f1 car to a
spaceship where things go even faster
so i'm going to quickly wrap things up
now
firstly during the pandemic there were
no in-person conferences so a bunch of
us decided to spend our time in a useful
way
and we created this github account
called dvd crew
great place to start
practical techniques
things you can apply
how to like combine event storming
example mapping all these different kind
of techniques definitely recommend that
if you're at the start of your journey
and you want to bring more
collaborative design into your team get
closer to the main experts
and then i've got four quick takeaways
i'd like to recap just to make sure i'll
get the key points across
but you might have different takeaways
if you do that's totally fine
the first one i would say is
going back to that feeling that they
were having about something's not right
here
if if
if changing your code is hard
if adding these new unexpected
requirements is is difficult
it might not be that your code is
is bad you might follow all of the
principles solid cupid's
whatever patterns and principles you
follow
you might be doing all of those things
well but it might be your understanding
of the domain that's not that's not at
the level you need to improve your code
second one is
about the relationship between you and
the domain yeah the domain drives your
code
but also you can drive the domain you
can add new concepts
try and find the sharepie in your domain
what's a concept that would make your
code better
and it would change your domain in a
positive way
also an investment you know think about
that decision with the project manager
he's like
i should make a meme about this like one
face happy one face set or something
didn't think of that but you know you've
got like
refactor the code over here
and and a deadline over here like which
one do you go
um for them the investment was worth it
so you know he's thinking about domain
modeling as an investment
um third point is
uh fourth point and the fourth point is
my my friends at the church of ddd
if you think about this chapter
to me it's the hidden treasure because
in this chapter he doesn't talk about
any of that stuff he doesn't talk about
bounded context she picks his language
he doesn't talk about any of that stuff
it's just the story of him and his team
solving some problems
in a in a logical way working with the
domain experts
emphasizing the problems we face on real
projects so i think you can get all of
these benefits
even if you don't do domain driven
design buy the book and use all the
terminology i still think these concepts
are more useful so i'm going to leave
you with three questions to think about
what would your alternative timeline be
what would you change about the major
design could be any if you could do
anything
if you want to send me your thoughts
afterwards please do that
if you if you can beat reducing the
whole book to one chapter i'll be
impressed but you know maybe i'm only
halfway up mount everest and there's
still loads more improvement possible
and also just just thinking about right
now like
which bit of the talk today is
still
there with you the most maybe you're
bored and not thinking about this talk
but if you if you are thinking about
this talk
which bit of it stands out to you the
most
and then take that feeling and think
about
why is that standing out to you maybe
it's something you don't do enough of or
maybe it's something you recognize or
just yeah think about what you can do
with that after this talk see if that's
something you should spend more time
thinking about maybe it's the part about
your team being more involved in
designing the product itself
whatever stands out to you yeah try and
follow that up see if it can be
something useful
and so
just as my nerves are starting to go
away we have reached the end of this
talk and you are now back in the
original dignity timeline thank you
you